in this scene we wanted to find a fun  way to introduce ik door and we also  want to establish the rules behind the  land of the dead so we ended up having  him be a celebrity tour guide kind of  like a guy who would drive around and  show tourists the Stars home yeah and he  held the promise of maybe getting Miguel  to mess with a la Cruz  [Music]  bienvenidos a feliz dia de los muertos  you seem like a great crowd better than  my last group what a bunch of stiffs a  bunch of stiffs when us not just Senor  what's your name how did you die oh and  you signora what's your name how did you  die who are you talking to  please hold off questions who's ready to  have a good time I am I can't hear you I  like it memory it's what keeps us all  alive as long as our families back home  remember us we live on in this beautiful  city excuse me again there will be time  for questions at the end now where was I  as long as our families back home  remember us we live out in this  beautiful city